ciao ragazzi bentornate la nuova puntata
di cucina buttata oggi sono molto
contento per comprende che mi piace
particolarmente ha deciso di darci
fiducia nonostante i nostri fallimenti
passati la metti la faccia al mondo
fondate rivoltato la riprendiamo fra tra
un po croce anche lasciamo riposare ma
non siamo qui per rimandare i nostri
errori anche perché con sa che bob è
difficile sbagliare io più del canale di
malta oltre a fare un piatto
spettacolare eri consumo sulla mia bocca
spettacolare di zoom alla fine faremo
una sfida pazzesca per assaggiare da
marco l'eolico non possiamo permetterci
di sbagliare
forse è meglio che me ne vada no se sai
che non si fida di me io devo fidarmi di
te ragazzi poi una soluzione delle
intese perché porti ti mostro
è un ala tre minuti e se a posto
capitolino ma che figura ci faccio così
che figura ci fa così facile serve
un'idea guglielmo ho un'idea the kids
tesi che potete mostro è uguale a tre
minuti essere apposta che nella stessa
cosa che ha fatto prima enrico identica
è infatti un trattato geniale cose
veicolo ho trovato l'idea il piatto che
fonde l'oriente coi miei fallimenti
seguite in cucina per fare nudo sala
willwoosh avremmo bisogno di una bag sec
e bon di jachy somma alle verdure 150
millilitri d'acqua salmone e semi di
papavero facendo le foto padella acqua
si e poi sul fuoco bravo a resistere
apriamo la peg dentro troviamo questo
sacchettino intanto che aspettiamo che
l'acqua bolla collabor ne all
93 aspettiamo la collabo la bolla
detto questo sacchettino dicevo abbiamo
sia la salsetta che metteremo alla fine
che è questa bustina di verdurine spes
ieri e dovremo infilare insieme ai
boodles nel momento in cui l'acqua bolla
in bolla questo qui ma abbiamo fatto la
stessa identica cosa
no perché voi non sapete come andrà
avanti ed è per questo che mi invita a
guardare tutto il video anche perché
l'unità per la fine lo potete immaginare
voglio vedervi cerca da caracas
effettivamente noi non abbiamo fatto con
jacques all'akragas cambia completamente
che sia così invito tutti quanti a
fascia che la carta e mi aiuterete chi
tifi coi capelli rossi in qualsiasi
fattore ne yo piccolo principe di saint
bon
certamente ho sempre preso quelli delle
cup e mi piace l'idea di poterli
riscaldare mangiare dico che ne so sul
divano cioè mi piace non apparecchiare
quando li mangia ci vediamo quasi si
scusa anche qui non puoi sbagliare da
lui e al mondo sa che quella della porta
le ragioni marcore mai detto che ti
fidavi di me ho mentito
ragazzi qui ci siamo quasi puoi saltar
di questi fis alto dice vai prova un
salto il po occhio perché l'errore è
dietro l'angolo anche la volta del
proprio dietro la regione ormai sento
odore di fallimento e dai buonisti sono
pronti guardate ai sogni
questo qui si potrebbe mangiare già così
si aggiungerà qualcosa io no sì online
niculai solmi e un album the chap detto
fatto
l'idea dai come fai a non sapevi e tupac
no bella prova per avvisare proprio le
cose che vengono dette va bene messo in
un piatto come ho fatto io presidenza
cucinati come ho fatto io lo sa qualcuno
la pentola è arrivato il momento del
twist alla uil bush non è che ti fa
schifo striati di un coltello
tagliamo il salmone se c'è qualche spina
la sentiamo e la togliamo con delle
pinzette tagliamolo sesamo 12345 di
pannella ma che calino bellissimo posso
dire una cosa
il salmone fatto così sembra una gran
figata assurdo è di una facilità estrema
[Musica]
malfidati vediamo se sembra la spugna
latina tv odio vago impiatta
importantissimo rosolate da tutti i lati
che dietro anche così è anche per il
lago 3a e come non mi fai ridere poi
dall'ato3 passiamo tutto siamo pronti
per il piazzamento signor capitano cosa
nelle modalità cinema si signor capitano
andiamo
[Musica]
prima della grande sfida finale faccio
un assaggio perché sono curioso di
mangiarla il cisco per questa roba
sì sì fare liechi somma di sake donna è
abbastanza facile
ecco perché ho deciso di rendere
difficile il momento in cui dovremo
mangiabile per cui inizia la sfida
mangia in maniera difficile è qualcosa
che ho fatto in maniera molto facile
sfida a mangiare con l'altra mano già io
con le bacchette non sono sto fenomeno
quinti gibelli nella soia è fa per
succedere
l'ultimo purché ripagano fatta bene
soprattutto perché tanto è ancora ok
tu mi stai fracassando della sfida
mangiare bendato sfida mangiare in
verticale paolo dobbiamo farlo davvero
posso fare
[Musica]
siamo sicuri che ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video come sempre
grazie mille sa che bonn per aver
creduto in noi speriamo di averti reso
giustizia noi ci vediamo martedì con un
altro blog e vorrei chiedervi di
commentare qui sotto facendomi sapere in
che modo mangereste i sai che molla i
commenti migliori riprenderemo e li
proveremo a fare su instagram
ciao
tra i due hanno voluto pronunciare anche
ad horas a cantù adesso con cui parlare
quando mi pare non ingaggiarlo quando
sto con john deacon sia trinità stati
negati scusa ragazzi e gli oggetti di
scena che va regolato geniale e to fail
in the usa che abbiamo sbagliato
[Musica]